صباح الخير لكم صباح الخير لجميع
المشاهدين حول العالم الطقس اليوم ضبابي
شفتوا كيف التغير المناخي صاروا
الطقس ضبابي ونيتك صافيه اقول اكيد راح
يتعدل وكان في مطر امبارح بالليل يلا عليك
بالعافيه ان شاء الله خلينا نحكي عن
اخبارنا قول نعم يعني بالرغم من تواجد
السائح الروسي والاوكراني في منتجعات
الجزر اليونانيه في عز ازمه كورونا الا ان
هذا السائح يتغيب عن المنطقه هذا الصيف
بنسبه 70% بسبب الوضع السياسي في البلدين
ما دفع اصحاب الفنادق هنا في جزر اليونان
بالبحث عن زبائن اخرين وذلك باعتماد اسلوب
السياحه اليونانيه الداخليه تم اقامه
حملات دعائيه في معظم مدن اليونان
الشماليه بنعرف انه بالشمال في ثلوج في
اليونان والعاصمه طبعا لتحفيز سكان تلك
المدن لزياره جزر بلدها من اليونان ومن
بين اليافطات الدعائيه كتب على البعض منها
هل تعتقد انك تعرف بلدك ووضعت صوره او
الصوره الخلفيه لتلك الانفطار كانت مكونه
من صور فوتوغرافيه حرفيه لشواطئ جزر
يونانيه خلابه دون ذكر اسم الجزيره
كتب يعني
كتب فقط هنا اليونان على تلك اليافطات دون
ذكر اسم الجزيره على طرف الصوره وبشكل
موازي قامت شركه الملاحه البحريه الوطنيه
اليونانيه بزياده عدد البواخر التي تحمل
السياح ومركباتهم ونقلها من موانئ كبرى
المدن اليونانيه وتكثيف عدد الرحلات
البحريه من جزيره لاخرى باسعار مخفض هذا
الخبر الاول يعني موضوعك ثاني ايضا يتعلق
بالسياحه ولكن سياحه الطعام على ما يبدو
بانه كل المطاعم تتسابق عشان تفتح اليونان
تحديدا في الجزر شو السلافه
بالفعل بالفعل راويه
وهناك جدل وكثير من تلك المطاعم العالميه
التي اليوم بدات تفتح ابوابها ليس فقط في
المدن الرئيسيه الكبرى بل ايضا في
المنتجعات والفنادق الفخمه فهنا مثلا في
هذه القريه خلفي
ما اثار غضب بعض السكان المحليين الذين
يفضلون ان يتعرف السائح على الاطباق
اليونانيه من جهه اخرى يرغب السائح ان
يتذوق اطباق غير يونانيه اثناء اقامته
التي قد تصل احيانا الى اسبوعين او اكثر
من ذلك وهنا يدافع اصحاب المنتجعات عن
انفسهم بالقول ليس من المعقول تناوله ذات
الاطباق اليونانيه اليونانيه لمده شهر
كامل ما دفعنا الى فتح مطاعم عالميه من
باب التنوع او التنويع وه مطاعم عالميه
فتحت ابوابها كالمطعم اليوناني
سماسون طبعا في هنا في هولندا ايرلندا
الذي لاق الكثير من الذي شجع وجوده والبعض
يعارض بشكل قطعي هذا جدل مع وضد هنا في
اليونان خصوصا في هذا الصيف فالكثير بنعرف
يعني يعتاش الكثير من سكان القرى الجبليه
خلفي او حتى الساحليه من وجود السائح لبيع
منتجاتهم او ماكولاتهم واطباقها عليك بالف
عافيه ليث استمتع وكل عني وعن راويه وعن
طاقم العمل
من جزيره
شكرا
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات